welcome to everybody we are standing by
in Arizona where Donald Trump has been
touring a Honeywell factory and is soon
going to be speaking and being involved
in a roundtable on supporting the Native
American community which seems almost
laughable that these are things he knows
anything about nor cares anything about
but this has been the focus now it is
get away from talking about the virus
itself talk about economics talk about
how good economics by that I mean the
stock market and opening businesses talk
with no real understanding of actual
economic policy or Theory talk about
whatever the death goal the death toll
is how he has saved us from millions
more deaths we'll talk about that in a
little bit that has been the strategy
scheduled for the bottom of the hour
some confusion about the scheduling
because let me actually pull this up
this confused any number of people let
me see if I've got it here here is
Donald Trump's daily schedule and what
you will notice that's unless they fixed
it okay so according to this they seem
to real so Arizona does this weird thing
where I guess they don't change the
clocks so part of the year there are
three hours behind the East Coast and
part of the year they're two hours
behind so as you all can tell we are
getting close to 4:30 p.m. on the East
Coast they have Trump scheduled to leave
on a flight at 4:20 p.m. Eastern saying
that that's 120 local they correctly
assess that there's a three-hour
difference but they don't seem to
understand that the that the time that
he's doing this event is 4:30 p.m. they
thought it was 3:30 p.m. it's a mess I
mean it's just it all of it is a mess
the point is it's apparently starting
relatively soon you've got what seems
like masked up security or Secret
Service here already
Trump asked about whether he will wear a
mask let's take a look at that video and
see what he said
yeah I think it's the best facility
right if it's a mask facility I will
yeah I don't know if it's advanced
facility but when you go to see
Honeywell they have done an incredible
job yelling over the choppers of course
that's that's not true let's actually
pull up the latest testing numbers and
you will quickly see we don't have
enough testing we are we are so listen I
mean I'll admit we have more testing
than we did five weeks ago that that's
good but we still are only testing about
250 K a day we need to be at double that
to then double it again to then double
it again I mean with listen we you know
500 we we don't even have a conversation
until we get to 500,000 tests every day
and we still can't seem to get past
roughly 250 got to 298 on Friday so
Trump very very much wrong about that as
he is wrong about many many things
welcome to everybody watching on Twitter
twitch YouTube and Facebook I very much
appreciate everybody who's joining me
today Donald Trump had a quiet day off
yesterday just sending about 40 rage
tweets but nothing official on his
schedule and he is back to work today
a few super chats that have come in if
you are watching on YouTube and you want
to join the conversation send a super
chat using the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window they'll show up in
the lower left I will read a few of them
now Kevin mccomber says doesn't mass
immigration hurt American workers I mean
listen if you double the number of
people looking for jobs
certainly that conceivably would with
lower wages
that's not what we have we have
extensive coverage of that on our
YouTube channel
unknown prodigy says the new death
goalpost is 100,000 I love winning yep
we can look at that briefly the United
States death toll now
oh just what we've been chatting 200
people died of the virus has now it's
approaching 70 mm remember Trump said we
were looking at 60 K mmm then he started
saying maybe 70 80 now he's saying 80 90
we heard about a hundred the new IH Emmy
model says it's gonna be more like a
hundred and thirty five Justin wave one
we have a trump FEMA and CDC document
which says we could actually be looking
at three thousand deaths a day come June
first I mean it's really crazy really
really crazy what's going on and we are
just absolutely blowing past this number
did you guys just lose me on Facebook
that's something weird just happened
there I just got a ping that something's
strange
oh everything seems to have done has my
entire internet collapsed
that's weird uh what on earth just
happened my stream still appears to be
live but we're back to live here
twitch is good oh it seems maybe it was
a YouTube issue I'm not actually sure oh
but my restream thing is also kind of
tweaking that's really weird
oh no restream does say that I'm live
all right I guess there was a momentary
glitch I don't know what what happened
there everybody says that things are
okay okay good all right we're still on
okay let's continue
Steven Barnett the second says all
continue to roasts people not social
distancing yeah today I walked to the
post office brought my mask and
everything and I walked by one of the
phone zombies who's just walking like
this and no awareness that we have a
wide sidewalk you can keep your distance
I was pressed up against the wall like
this and you know I did the half turn
and then the full turn that that's how I
look at people when they don't social
distance I go like this when they when
they get right up on me and it worked
this person noticed what they were doing
and they stepped away and it was it was
beautiful it all worked exactly as
planned SEF Barham says hey David
thoughts on the grim new government data
100,000 seems like an under estimate
from Trump yeah at this point it seems
like it's going to be more and let me
see where where are we today today so
far the United States has seen again
almost 2000 deaths
it's it's 2,000 a day you know we had a
day or two where it was lower we can
pull up our charts here where was that
yeah so we had a couple days where it
was lower we had 11 53 and then 13 24
we're back up to 1800 today and it seems
to you know you could you can make the
matoke mathematical case that these
Peaks are a little lower each time so
you know hopefully it would lower over
time but if these numbers continue
roughly we are going to have a hundred
thousand deaths very very soon you're
absolutely right Seth Hillis total says
Messi or Ronaldo I'm from Argentina of
course Messi
Daniel Rivera says love the clean new
email newsletter layout thank you oh
yeah let me actually talk to people
about that so we've been we've had a
very very lame not interactive
newsletter for years okay where every
day it would just go out and it was just
a list of topics you couldn't comment on
it it was lame it didn't have rich
embedded media or anything like that
yesterday we switched our newsletter to
sub stack and it's unbelievable people
are going off though people are pulling
their hair out ripping it out and
destroying computers and musical
instruments because they're just so
fired up by our new newsletter and let
me tell you Daniel this is a
transitional phase okay
you can go to david pakman.com and sign
up it's free ok this is this is all free
we're gonna have a paid up we actually
already have a paid option and five or
ten people signed up right now it's
basically the show rundown you can click
and listen to the podcast you can watch
the YouTube clips you can see everything
that's on the show and you can
comment okay you never used to be able
to comment on our newsletters now you
can eventually we are going to be
transitioning this into almost like the
print version of the David Pakman show
we're going to continue expanding this
and it's going to contain more and more
content written content a lot of people
say I would love to be able to scroll
through a transcript of the show and
read it on the way to work remember when
people had on the way to work that was a
whole other universe it feels like but
we're gonna keep expanding this and it's
totally free so you can you can sign up
for it either at david pakman.com put in
your email or david pakman.com i think
that there's gonna be some really really
crucial elements communicated with that
very very soon okay continuing to look
at super chats let's see what is on
people's minds marcus gillard says keep
up the good work I'm a new member thank
you oh I haven't even been looking at
whether people have been oh there are
some new memberships I miss okay a
Jonathan Joyner is new member number one
today at joined pakman.com thanks
Jonathan very much appreciate that okay
ken Clive says 45 needs to work on his
sales copy among 499 other things such
as critical thinking Danny Thompson says
Trump sounds like a morbid auctioneer on
numbers dead on numbers dead I don't
know I don't know what that means oh oh
when talking about the number of deaths
oh oh you know what I this is I think
people are going to find this
interesting let me just show you
something so I'm still researching this
okay so I don't want to get ahead of
myself but a neuroscientist got in touch
with me and said you know David you're
talking about Trump's cognitive decline
you're talking about possible upper use
or all of these different things
dementia you need to consider the
symptoms of schizophrenia Trump has
every one of these okay so when you talk
about look at look at these symptoms
okay
Trump has every single one so semantic
processing disturbances including
difficulties with Lex
selection and retrieval Trump has that
remember the oranges of this
investigation disturbances in priming
reduced proactive inhibition we're gonna
go through every single one of these in
on the show in the future on a discourse
level they show difficulties with
coherently generating a narrative
remember Trump's dr. John Trump Uncle
John Trump MIT rant difficulty
generating a narrative coherently
absolutely other related disturbances in
schizophrenic language include
neologisms word approximation
disturbances in cohesion vague
references missing information and
confused references it's everything ok
add a syntactic grammatical level
patients with schizophrenia disorder
produce sentences with reduced syntactic
complexity Trump speaks with the lowest
complaintants complexity of any recent
president less dependence it should be
fewer and embedded clauses we talk about
how Trump uses very simple short
sentences which he often repeats and use
fewer connective markers Donald Trump
halts and says another thing and another
thing there's very few connective
markers but lastly hold on where was
this last part okay compared with normal
speech it contains more hesitations and
pauses and longer pauses and the
intonation is flat monotonous again that
is what Danny Thompson is saying Trump
sounds like a morbid auctioneer when he
talks about the number of deaths I'm
seeing everything there my friends I am
seeing absolutely everything there and
we will we will talk about that more
upcoming okay Matt Chavez says I hate
that Trump is just a few miles away from
me okay let's see what's going on here
looks like things are getting closer to
starting Marcos Gillard says what are
the current testing numbers just curious
oh we just went through those I don't
know if you missed them but we put them
up on the screen here they are yesterday
231,000 tests were done still about half
of where we need to be at an absolute
minimum Matthias
Germany says David do you ever had the
idea to be a teacher I taught a class at
Boston College in 2017 and that's that's
then I've taught individual classes as a
career it's not interesting to me I'm
happy with what I'm doing
Kevin mccomber says Israel or Palestine
that's I mean that's a completely
black/white unnecessarily black/white
way of looking at an issue that's
complex Kevin Macomber says make sure to
read all chats before the stream ends
that's not always possible my friend but
I will do what I can
David bielski says can you stop using
the word triggered I know you're trying
to take the edge off the word that Trump
errs use but it sounds like a
pretentious buzzword coming from anyone
be more creative I like triggered I find
it to be a funny word to use in the
context of Trump being easily triggered
I love it hella cool guy says has anyone
really been far even as decided to use
I'm having trouble parsing the grammar
there mister lieutenant pink says do you
think nationalism will have an impact on
the global availability and
affordability of a vaccine particularly
if Trump's US develops it yeah vaccine
access is a major issue very very
important question which we've been
talking about Charlie says holy cow that
schizophrenia stuff is insanely accurate
for Trump I was stunned when I saw him
Chris McCarthy says should ubi be part
of a progressive platform moving forward
I'm not opposed to that it it's an issue
of what else is on the platform it needs
to be coherent Li a part of it
David H says love your show but your
support of Biden is disappointing let's
support this horrible person because
this person is more horrible doesn't
work listen it's Trump or Biden and
Trump is way worse and I'm not gonna
help Trump win that's just it you're not
gonna get me to help Trump win I hope
people understand that so it's Trump or
Biden I'm not going to vote for a third
party that could help from Blaine I'm
not gonna vote for Trump which would
help Trump win I'm not gonna stay home I
I want Biden over Trump support of Biden
come on dude give me a break
give me a break no says roll EEGs
love from BC
Maddie I speedy says David Trump's
behavior also mirrors OCD unknown
prodigy says my mommy says hi we are
watching you together okay Jennifer
Maddox says Trump is the DJ Kahlid of
presidents yeah I don't know exactly
what you have in mind but certainly it
doesn't sound outrageous
it doesn't sound outrageous to me let me
say a huge thank you to some twitch
subscribers a beautiful way to support
the streams is to sign up at twitch.tv
slash david pakman chill SD has
subscribed and says keep up the good
work David enjoy your commentary rkj has
subscribed with prime first port which
has subscribed with prime and Durham
twitch has subscribed with prime also
mother Phi ker
careful now mother Phi Kerr has
subscribed with prime so has soda champ
and Rodimus Prime thanks to everybody
remember if you have Amazon Prime at
which Prime subscription is free I think
you find out about those elements at
twitch amazon.com if I recall correctly
Kevin Macomber says I'm not voting at
all don't like either candidate okay
that helps Trump that helps Trump Jeremy
comfort says can we do Trump bingo again
if we get back to a normal press
briefing I will do it I don't know that
the bingo works as well in an event like
what we're going to be experiencing
today insane Lane says David have you
read either of the books she said or all
the presidents women no I have not
Robert mifflin says left
non-interventionism versus right
isolationism I have so many videos about
topics like that I have one today about
social democracy versus populism which I
encourage you to check out if you were a
member you would already have full
access but lets us save that for a
different type of event people says in
the words of bad tan man Trump theft
sefa hide that's right I've been going
around
my girlfriend is really annoyed because
I keep using the term have sefa hide and
she's not thrilled with it she's not
thrilled with it at all okay um
has this started no it hasn't started
okay good somebody said it had started
but it didn't I thought I had missed the
FSF ahead okay Zach Bushman says
armchair psychiatry is irresponsible
Trump is not schizophrenic maybe he has
schizotypal personality disorder but
none of us are qualified to say it
sounds like you've been sort of trapped
by the Goldwater rule which numerous
mental health professionals on my
program have already pointed out really
was created specifically for political
reasons to shield Barry Goldwater from
criticism and that when it comes to a
public figure like Donald Trump the
Goldwater rule of so-called armchair
Psychiatry really doesn't apply this
isn't my opinion this is that of
numerous mental health professionals
that I have interviewed so that's into
the we can debate it certainly but
that's that's something important to
keep in mind whoa super chats are
exploding Ron says in 2021 either Trump
or Biden will be President not voting or
voting third party won't change that why
is it so hard for some people to
understand why doesn't Trump understand
how tariffs work you know I don't know
the answer but I'm doing what I can to
explain it to people
Audrey comer says Trump has a
narcissistic personality disorder
disorder
Kevin mccomber says not voting helps
Trump you could say the same for vide
Biden know if you don't if you don't
like Trump you are helping Trump get one
vote closer to re-election if you do not
vote okay that's the important thing to
understand Andre are says hey David
following you from Germany love your
show have you seen the Trump documentary
on Netflix no I have not Norwegian trad
Archer says is it only me or is
Americans really so naive
as it seems when it comes to many of the
comments from Donald Trump I don't know
that it's naivete or
neiva D as I heard one person say it I
say naiveté I don't know that it's
naivete or cognitive dissonance and or
ignorance I think that it's a
combination of elements big thank you to
the boy fifty boy who has subscribed
with twitch prime SPT Stan MoMA Lee Stan
mama Lee has subscribed with prime and
it's desam has subscribed with prime as
well a danny thompson says if the US
task force is truly truly is disbanded
in a few weeks
does it signal Trump is setting up pens
to take blame for federal failures no
Trump's going to pretend there were no
federal failures and that anything bad
that happened is because of the
governor's that's the way he's going
then does Trump replace pens with nikki
Haley on the ballot no no I don't think
so
nico princes says keep it up Colin
macmorrow says for the love of God
please get together with Kyle kolinsky
and debate about voting for Biden this
no Biden movement is getting absolutely
bananas I don't know what's going on I
couldn't I have no idea what can I
my I'm either reading to prepare for the
show or if i watch youtube videos which
i watch like 20 maybe 20 minutes a day
of YouTube videos I'm either watching
chess instructional videos espresso and
coffee making related videos can you
imagine how alpha is that behavior
sometimes I'll watch sort of like
sustainable off-the-grid type you know
boating or like living on a sailboat
building an island home where it you get
you grow at you know stuff like that
or I recently have been watching the
last dance Michael Jordan Chicago Bulls
documentary but I'm not yeah I just
don't watch any any of this stuff what's
going on now what is this
task force that's getting together data
and so we're just really needing help in
that in that sense and so we don't want
to lose any more of our native sisters
our Native mothers and so the cry is is
you know to get the awareness what on
earth this is the round table okay we're
gonna keep this muted for now we were
waiting for Trump's statements at
Honeywell it looks like they must be
running incredibly behind incredibly
behind so we're gonna keep an eye on
this and also on the White House feed
but this is odd this is all very very
weird but we're standing by also the
table is not round and I'm finding
myself bothered by that
look at how they put like a little
presidential seal in front of what
looked to be like whiteboards or poster
board it's weird okay but we're gonna
we're gonna keep an eye on this and we
will we'll we'll get to this as soon as
Trump remarks start it's like an
off-center shot I don't know what this
is but the White House stream we are
still waiting for and we will keep an
eye on that let me say thank you to
Robert Allard whose new member number
two today at join pakman.com as well as
Brett Markman who is new member number
three today at join pakman.com very much
appreciate that let me remind you fine
folks the best way to support our work
which includes the daily podcast youtube
clips a TV show radio show live streams
new interactive newsletter all of this
stuff truly the best way is put the
Schwab's down and grab a membership at
join pakman.com three people have done
it memberships are cheap were primarily
funded by memberships we had a tragic
event actually in in March in April
which is 722 people 722 people canceled
memberships because of the virus I get
what's going on we're all in this
together we fortunately have had several
hundred folks make up for it by grabbing
memberships during my live streams
I don't want your last dollar I don't
want your last two dollars but if you're
doing okay and you value what we do
the clips the podcasts the streams all
of it grab a membership at join
pakman.com it's quick it's easy you get
a lot of extra content and most
importantly I will Thank You profusely
live on stream and there's very few
things better than that other than
hearing Donald Trump drop half sefa Hyde
again which would be I admit if Trump
did have sefa Hyde again it would be
better than a membership but short of
that memberships are the best and we do
have this coupon code here available
2020 now you save 66% if you apply that
coupon code to a membership don't feel
obligated I mean really do not feel
obligated but take the discount down to
2 bucks a month if you so please drop it
even further to a dollar 80 a month if
you pay for the entire year at once okay
it looks like people want to hear a
little bit of what's going on here let's
see I hope it helps a lot not just a
little bit a lot yeah and I think he'll
do a fantastic job but are you going to
be watching it personally and
do we do the review and everyone else
that I know so well I think you're gonna
do a great job so go get them thank you
I'd like to maybe finish off with the
governor great governor you're doing a
phenomenal job bizarre you have to say
well my my mind can thankfully is
working first I want to say Thank You
mr. president were we're thrilled that
you're back in Arizona especially to
talk these specific tribal issues I want
to say to second lady Lizer to a vice
president Lizer to governor Lewis this
focus that we've had on our tribal
nations first and foremost around the
coronavirus with a special shout out to
Senator misete mcsalley who advocated
for the Trump is really going out of his
way to avoid actually talking about the
virus isn't it my my best to to
president Ness and I'm so grateful mr.
president that you took a personal
interest in getting these falater's to
Navajo Nation and I'm proud mr.
secretary in Arizona our our legislature
absolute just nonsense propaganda we're
gonna keep an eye on when Trump goes to
this signing and statement and and all
of the stuff we're going to keep an eye
on it but I want to hear from you guys I
want to hear from you guys okay a rich
ropa thak says watching American Pie
Tara Reid is a great actress okay whoops
I just lost some super chats there where
did those go Zach Bushman says not
defending the Goldwater rule you were
right on that but schizophrenia is a
huge reach in any case I think Trump is
schizophrenic what I'm telling you as a
neuroscientist wrote to me and said look
at how Trump speech patterns match those
of schizophrenia
Elzbieta Marciniak sends a super chat
kevin mccomber says there are worse
things than four more years of Trump
like backing another neoliberal
corporate hack because at least he's not
the other guy no that is that is a
revolutionary mentality I would argue
that if you look at the United States if
you look at when the biggest progressive
advancements have happened they have
been advancements of incrementalism
working within the system and so I
refuse to do anything that will let
Donald Trump choose the next Supreme
Court justice I don't want it to be
Trump I want it to be Biden there will
be
multiple generations that we'll be
better off as a result of that so
everybody can do what they want
everybody can do what they want to do
but just understand you know just own
that your actions help Trump I would
respect a lot of these folks if instead
of saying never Biden or you know the
lesser of two evils is still evil or you
know this sort of revolutionary stuff
just say I'd rather Trump than Biden
just to say you would rather it and then
we can have a real conversation about
what the impacts of that are that that
should be the starting point for the
conversation is it is acceleration ax
Steve history has shown so far that
acceleration ISM
okay nasty questions says let's hear
some nasty questions aka real questions
hopefully we will jacob Ratner says
thoughts on armed Michigan protesters
I'm against them and I have a story
about it on today's show AASK DL UK says
will we have Trump Biden debates I hope
we do
James Dorn says ignorant sand arrogance
is a dangerous combination
well said Michael Kern's sends a super
chat Jennifer Higgins Oh Trump is
signing hold on
I want to congratulate you
for also because I've I've been in that
vicinity and it's one of the most
beautiful places you can imagine so
congratulations very much okay
this is like
your neighbors field
and holding it up there it is present
what are your thoughts on winding down
the corona fires task force one second
yes sir no sir
oh they're gonna be questions okay so
looking out we're gonna keep an eye out
if the questions do be good what make
sure they everybody looks big thanks to
everybody signing up on Twitch by the
way I do see them with this part having
trouble keeping up there but I really
[Music]
read ribbon in remembrance of this
significant moment for missing and
murdered Native Americans and again I
want to thank you for making such an
announcement today and for for signing
an important document to commemorate the
National Day of awareness and and and I
know that your administration also made
another very important announcement
video regarding the corona virus relief
fund and thank you for that and to take
a few moments to comment about that as
well I want to thank of course the
reducing in and Senator McNally for
advocating and for making sure that this
is getting out to to the Indian country
this much-needed resources as well and
you know so today your administration
made a significant impact across Indian
country and I want to thank you for
getting some of the money out today I
want to thank you also because we need
help now Indian tribes and can't wait
for that litigation to end before
additional payments are made to us from
the fund and if you can please direct
the Treasury to make these payments as
soon as possible and three you know we
need to spread the limited resources
currently available as far as we can and
to avoid allocating to a very few tribes
and under allocating to most others and
this means that you should include a
limit or count on the total funding any
one tribe receives and we need to have
flexible guidance to allow us to use the
funds we do to receive that we receive
to keep our governments running mr.
president and the current fund of eight
billion dollars is
is going to be woefully inadequate to
meet our overall I don't know if Trump's
gonna like this and we will work with
Senator Bakk Sally and your
administration about to take this to the
next level and I look forward to working
with Senator McCauley
with the new chief of staff meadows
about Congress and your administration
on the next relief bill mr. president
thank you to make sure that your
investments in Indian country are going
where they are needed the most in a way
that shows that our governments and our
economic entities can be part of that
recovery that we are talking about here
that will be critical as we come out of
this crisis and rebuild our tribal state
and national economy together with
Indian country included mr. president I
always end my my video messages to my
community members we're all in this
together
and to continue to be Gila River strong
and I think that is how that we can
continue to be Gila River strong and to
strengthen all tribal nations moving
forward mr. president
thank you very much Steven I appreciate
have to say my route Eliza and I are
dealt and we've our people have dealt
together very closely in the second lady
I don't fully understand a lot of
progress has been made and will continue
to make a lot of progress I think you'll
see that and I think you've received not
only here but in the future thank you
very much and I appreciate it very much
Thank You governor thank you thank you
you with the administration he has good
genes know who's got good genes right
the Scalia genes you don't get better
than that day you go ahead you down the
task force vice president pence said
there are discussions underway about
winding down the task force is that a
good idea during a pandemic well I think
we're looking at phase two and we're
looking at other phases the country
starting to open up the task force has
done a phenomenal job we have a chart
that I just showed somebody we just got
it this morning as I was getting off the
plane okay
the and Governor Ducey can explain it
better than we came in ventilators were
a very very big deal and very hard to
produce inside say but it is largely
true the complexity is sort of like
building a car we opened up operations
all over the country to build them and
we there was has been one person that
needed a ventilator that didn't get it
in a few days and they were helping
other countries and we're stockpiling in
case some tragedy like this happens
again but this just came out on testing
because I think we are at the plate on
testing these numbers oh my god what a
lot
we just released and this is the United
States the amount of testing and our
level of testing and the quality of
testing that is literacy festival the
total number of laboratory that huge
line you see there goes to six million
we have 331 million people this guy's
holding up a graph of tests what how
does he still not get per capita I think
he's just gas lighting right like he
must understand per capita but he's just
gas lighting look at that pointing to
the line you have 331 million people in
the country that's a cart if you read
the book how to lie with statistics it's
by I forget the guys name Stanford
something I believe one of the things
they'll say is this is exactly how you
lie with statistics if we just sit down
here we would never in many cases say we
have more cases than anybody but the
fact is when you look at these numbers
this is the official cab now I can't
tell you whether or not other countries
are giving us the straight deal but I
can say that I know one thing so this
isn't the ocular trees come on these are
the United States and it's incredible
remember this and I think it's important
to say this Jim the quality of our test
is also the best of minutes acknowledged
to be the best so again when we have
cases and we have more cases than
anybody else does anybody really believe
that we have more cases than China but
they don't talk about numbers like this
and other countries but we report
everything and don't you want to Heidi I
just want to say that we've done an
incredible job in testing with that
being said we have some additional this
is completely Orwellian I hope people
understand the degree to which this is
Orwellian is stunning only to the
dumbest people would they fall for this
the task force to get this scientific
expertise we will have certain people
as an example we have hospitals that we
built we have medical centers that we
built we have people on the task force
that focus on that we have people on the
task force that's focused exclusively on
ventilators well we have more
ventilators now than anybody in the
world and we're helping France as you
know we're helping France Italy Spain
Nigeria we're just we're giving I think
250 to Nigeria we have many countries
that were helping but the ventilator
problem is soft so you don't need that
we have now a different it's sort of a
combination it makes sense to disband
the task force during a pandemic we have
plenty of ventilators that's the answer
and also we tested a lot of people I
think everybody out there when they're
being very honest I think the job we've
done on testing will shortly be and
maybe even supersede Doug the job that
we've done on ventilators which people
can't even believe we had a call the
other day with the governor's Mike Pence
took the call and they had I believe all
fifty-eight who was in the bathroom
tweeting it had it was they say the best
call we've had thus far with the
governor's have everything they need and
if they don't have it and if they don't
need it or if they can't get it locally
and then they know that we are stocked
and we are ready and we can have as an
example we won't need this but we were
ready for weeks to have we had 10,000
ventilators sitting in various locations
with people by the ventilator notice the
question had nothing to do with
ventilators they'd have to do with we're
in a pandemic why would you disband your
pandemic task force your uh coronavirus
task force for the country so I think
that as far as the task force Mike Pence
and the task force have done a great job
but we're now looking at a little bit of
a different form and that form is safety
and opening and we'll we'll have a
different group probably so they pulled
the doctors out from the briefings and
then now they're gonna just fire them
this is when it's over when it's over
Jim mission accomplished tough I woulda
said
are you certain you will get the advice
you need and health-wise
what does that mean go ahead repeat your
question medicine advice that you need
great advice we have great people we
have great people yeah we have great
doctors we have great medical people
laboratory people I have to say I think
tremendous progress is being made on
vaccines which everybody should be very
happy to hear and therapeutically I
think would make you very good progress
too and we're making tremendous progress
we have the greatest doctors in the
world the greatest laboratories in the
world that I have to say what 1,000
people are dying today in the US we're
working with UK will still with Germany
were working with various other nations
who are very advanced and doing a good
job
I think therapeutically and also from
the standpoint of laboratories we are
laboratories as it pertains to vaccines
we're doing very well I'd love to see a
therapeutic answer even before we ever
see dr. pouchy publicly with Donald
Trump again current problem or dilemma
but therapeutically and for the vaccines
a tremendous amount of progress
Oxford Johnson & Johnson incredible
places are doing I think a really good
job and they're very advanced but we
have to now see we're going up to that
very delicate final stage with a number
I think in a number we still have 2,000
deaths a day we're not final stage what
is this guy talking about just so you
know working very closely with other
countries and whoever gets it first my
hat's off to him we're not looking for
first second to third we're looking to
get a vaccine that works and progress
has been made
just to follow up on Jim's question with
the doctor saying that there might be a
recurrence of the corona virus in the
fall why can you just explain why is now
the time to wind down bat task force
well because we can't keep our country
close for the next five years you know
you could say that might be a recurrence
I mean the task force doesn't preclude
you from opening if this is completely
incoherent I mean this is weaponized in
coherence we must remove this man you
know we've learned a lot about the
corona virus we've learned a lot about
this hidden enemy it's a it's a
dangerous enemy it's a bad enemy you see
what it does especially for people over
a certain age and people that have a an
infirmity if you have diabetes if you
have a bad heart if you have a certain
problem it just
miron it just goes after you it's
vicious and we're saying that people
that are over 60 65 but over 60 we're
even saying they're sort of stay back
for a while we recommend you staying
back for a while at the same time with
young children and children we'd like to
see the schools open early next season
and on time it's incredible how the it's
very unique how the children aren't
affected but people that have problems
and older people are can be very badly
hurt injured or died from we know I just
want to finish the follow up if I
understand you don't want to keep the
country closed for five years but don't
you want your advisors to keep looking
at this closely the way you have looking
at it very closely they are looking at
very closely and and I tell I just said
it today I used the word for the first
time I think in terms of what we're
doing
viewing our great citizens of this
country to a certain extent and to a
large extent as warriors the warriors
warriors who we can't keep our made eyes
we have to own our country somebody said
oh we could keep it for the next 18
months we could keep it for the next two
years Doug Ducey's done an incredible
job as the governor of Arizona that's
not gonna do it everything people aren't
going to accept it they won't accept it
and they shouldn't accept it we have a
great country we can't keep it closed I
mean I've had doctors say well why don't
we close it for a couple of years
because the United States of America I
can't imagine with many people
associated with a lot of other people I
hope people real issen let let me tell
you guys something it's May 5th okay
March 5th 60 days ago give or take a day
March 5th we had 221 cases 221 March 5th
China had 80,000 cases and March 5th
Italy had 4,000 cases so on March 5th we
knew it was going beyond China when it
does it can get bad very quickly as it
was doing in Italy and we had 221 cases
not one not 15 that would have been the
time for Trump to say I need everybody
together on this right now we need to do
a stay at home in all 50 states get
together with me governor's if we do
this by May 5th today we would be in
good shape we all know how that went
we all know how that went didn't happen
again plan in terms of our symptoms our
cases our hospital capacity our ability
to search on our testing and we're going
to continue to put public health first
but we know so much more today
than we did six or eight weeks ago so we
believe that we want to protect our most
vulnerable those are the folks that are
of a certain age with the underlying
health condition but the first objective
was that the largest places were shut
down Major League Baseball made the
decision to shut down spring training
those are some of the best weeks of the
year oh my god this guy thinks this is
about sports played opening day schools
are not in session so these large
gathering places have dispersed we've
been able to address the fact that we
have hospital capacity ICU capacity and
ventilator capacity if it's necessary
today it doesn't look as it will be so
we have our arms around the public
health emergency in Arizona and the
president the vice president and the
medical experts along with the cabinet
secretaries have given the latitude to
governor's to make decisions and what's
the in the best public health interest
of their state Arizona is is not New
York State it wasn't hit first it wasn't
hit that hard we've learned a lot from
what those states have gone through and
we're gonna apply it to predict you
looking like an Arizona do you still
want the advice of doctors vowed she at
dr. Burks will they still be involved
even once the task force's okay yeah
they will be and so will other doctors
and soullow they're okay
experts in the field but we've learned a
lot as Doug says we've learned a lot so
understand this yesterday Arizona had
279 new cases today Arizona has 386
right that's about a 30% increase in new
cases today over yesterday these aren't
good numbers these are the numbers that
if they stay like this for 10 more days
Arizona is a hot spot and nobody seems
to understand the numbers as they should
a very successful transition back into
the real world
and then you can have a fourth quarter
that I think is going to do very well
and then I think next year I think we're
gonna have one of the best years we've
ever had
building on stimulus and we have a pent
up demand like I have never seen before
you know today's a very interesting day
because it's my first day out and duck
reminded me of something I didn't do it
for that reason but you said this is the
first place you stopped when you ran
when I ran for something that turned out
to be a very successful run we had
tremendous crowds you remember at the
convention center in Phoenix and it was
pretty incredible and I didn't do it for
that reason interestingly but here we
are and it was great that you will find
us of that fact but look we're going to
have a very interesting transition
period into the fourth quarter I think
you turn pent up demand
it's literally wrong I mean what you
have in a recession depression is there
is no demand for stuff I think what
Trump means by pent up demand is people
are miserable that they don't have money
for stuff people would love to be buying
things and demanding them in the
economic sense but people don't have
money but pent up demand is literally
the opposite of what we currently have
in economic terms mic standpoint purely
an economic standpoint I think next
year's potentially going to be one of
the best years we've had this tremendous
stimulus out there and people want to
get out they want to go and they want to
go to town this country was was founded
on certain principles and those
principles are at work like you've never
seen before so I want to thank you all
very much you thank you and we'll see
you perhaps at the next step
there's a virus vaccine will you get it
will you take it will I take it if they
would like me to enjoy the first one if
they were to the last one I don't want
to waste it but he's just saying if
there's a vaccine would you take it and
she might like it that it didn't work
too well okay but that's okay
I would absolutely Jim if there's a
vaccine and if they wanted me to be
first online I'd be first online or it'd
be last on line or I wouldn't take it at
all whatever's best for the country
Wow there you go
so I guess the next thing is Trump goes
to Honeywell
I mean we're still trying to figure out
like what the exact schedule is let me
pull up Trump's schedule again it seems
like everything is very delayed so okay
a president arrives president departs
president arrives at Honeywell at 1:55
p.m. Eastern president is in a
roundtable at 2:00 p.m. it's now 5:00
p.m.
these these are Eastern Times at 2:00
p.m. so ok president is in a tour of
Honeywell at 12:15 I think that that has
happened right then the president
delivers remarks at Honeywell
International at 3:00 I have no idea
what's going on with the schedule I
really really don't it's very unclear
this event was supposed to have started
half an hour ago and let's see if it's
even still going or it's been canceled
no I guess it's still no people are just
still waiting for this event
it's really weird guys I don't know what
the hell is going on I'm not I'm not
gonna lie
now they've switched to an Illinois
coronavirus briefing it is bizarre
it is absolutely bizarre yeah it
canceled if we have another feet does
anybody have another feed about what
might be going on let's see this I
believe was we had the Washington Post
so I don't really know oh this is from
earlier
here's a fox business feed but this is
not live either this is what we just
finished watching I guess they're
delayed by like four hours or something
like that I don't even know but if
somebody has another feed that they want
me to pull up I will I will gladly do it
let me know let me say a few member
thank-yous to get caught up here
James SUSE is new member number four
today at join pakman.com jose cruz is
new member number five at join
pakman.com chad Schlegel is new member
number six today at join pakman.com also
want to say thanks to sharon rozerr who
is new member number seven on my website
margie Vincent hey Margie Margie is a
great person and new member number eight
Rob jandreau is new member number nine
Jared Smith is number ten today Rick
Moser hey Rick is number eleven Courtney
Jones hi Courtney you are number twelve
today Michael Milliron is number
thirteen and I can't forget Jennifer's
on who is number fourteen today I
believe that Oh No Stephen Saunders I
forgot about is number fifteen thanks
Steven and also Brett Markman is number
sixteen Wow at join pakman.com a very
very popular stuff very very popular
stuff as Donald Trump likes to say okay
let's see here Robert Mifflin says 51%
of Bernie boaters are unlikely to vote
Biden what are your thoughts I don't
believe it I think it's most of them are
going to David Muir is interviewing
Trump live ABC World News now really ABC
World News now is interviewing Trump
live let's see here Jonathan Karl
because John that was striking an
acknowledgement from the president that
there could be lives here at risk and
the president has said David okay we'll
keep an eye on it ie still are having a
hard time figuring out exactly what the
hell is going on
let's see here Kevin Macomber says how
would dementia Joe handle coronavirus
better dementia Joe as you refer to him
literally wrote not the book wrote a
book on handling pandemics as part of
the Obama administration color-coded 69
page pandemic response playbook Trump
threw it out okay
Biden was involved in that manok these I
can tell Kevin you know I don't vote for
Biden dude like it's fine you don't you
don't have to do it just instead of
asking these lame questions just accept
you're gonna help Trump just say you'd
rather Trump or you're indifferent that
I would just be much more respectful of
that than asking obvious quick
how would Biden we'd be worse I can't
think of any way in which Biden would be
worse on dealing with the pandemic Conor
Brenner says Governor Ducey is trying to
open up some restaurants here with
social distancing practices on May 11
and album barber shops on May 8 he isn't
taking it seriously it certainly appears
to be that way I see people saying
different time zone David guys come on
you know it's like the this schedule is
Eastern Time and then it's local okay so
let me give you an example
Trump was supposed to leave to go back
to DC at 4:20 Eastern which was an hour
ago 120 local Arizona are people
trolling me or do you really think I
don't understand the time zones guys
it's right there the tie the schedule is
Eastern and they have local time here so
when people say David you're stupid this
was at a luck guys 2 p.m. Eastern 11:00
a.m. local was when the roundtable was
supposed to be it is three hours after
that right now again 3:30 p.m. Eastern
was supposed to be Trump's remarks at
Honeywell
12:30 in Arizona con give me a little
more credit guys please please I'm doing
what I can here give me a little bit
more credit
I understand time zones okay uh oh boy
alright let me say thanks to some people
on Twitch Alaska Pete has subscribed
with Prime
pensive has subscribed with prime will
SRX and craw in have all subscribed with
prime and also rusty knife has gifted a
subscription which I very very much
appreciate also want to say thanks to
Michael Sweeney who is new member number
17 today and Alexandra Metzger who is
new member number 18 okay I am being
notified that it could be a very long
time until the Honeywell thing if it
indeed happens so I think there's no way
I can hang for 90 minutes so I think
what we're going to do is we're gonna
end this stream now I'm gonna monitor
Trump's schedule while I work on
tomorrow's program because the show you
dope with the show continues and then
I'll be back if this event ends up
happening we saw some stuff GLAAD folks
join me thank you
you